let's talk about passion
um as far as mindset goes because i've
heard a lot of you know so-called gurus
and experts talk about
passion whether you should follow your
passion don't follow your passion follow
your passion
um and everything that's built around
that
um i'm gonna tell you that if you don't
have passion for what you're doing
it it's just not gonna work out it just
it just never does um
some people say well you know i can make
seven hundred thousand a million dollars
a year doing this but i don't have any
interest in it whatsoever or when you
start talking you discover they actually
hate what they're doing
and
it's it's just a [ __ ] place to be
because
why would you want to get inv like it's
like going out with a woman that you're
not attracted to let's just put it that
way right she's out of the weight
category that you like or she's too tall
or too short or she just doesn't have
the look if you know what i'm saying you
got to have passion you got to have that
genuine desire that i talk about in
chapter three but not for
a woman you're gonna have that genuine
burning desire for what it is that
you're building you actually have a
genuine interest in it and
i break down a lot of reasons why in
other parts of this course that i'm
building but the main reason why is if
you want a good chance of success
because nine out of 10 times you're
going to fail right you want a good
chance of success you want to know the
industry you want to have the contacts
you want to know who the competitors are
you don't want to get into something
that's completely brand new and green
for you you end up being a green horn in
a area where there's a lot of experts
that are they're basically going to
destroy you
it's it's generally not going to work
out so i would definitely make sure that
it's something that you have a genuine
interest in a strong genuine interest
and you're generally passionate about
um
let's see here hey guys give me uh give
me the thumbs up and a like please i see
that we got a good number of guys
watching get those likes up for me
um
let's talk about thinking types i think
i've covered this in a video before but
it's it's definitely worth
visiting again
there's three types of thinking methods
there's inside of the box
there's outside of the box and there's
not even seeing the box
most people
are programmed to be inside the box
thinkers
show up punch the clock do your work
take your 15-minute break do your work
take your 35-minute lunch do your work
take your break punch the clock go home
cross your t's dot your eye kiss your
wife when you walk in the door
pet billy on the head kiss sally you
know you get what i'm talking about like
most people are cookie cutter inside the
box thinkers okay and there's nothing
wrong with that you know like there's
there's
a vast majority of the population that's
always going to be there some of them
live wonderful lives some of them live
great lives right some of them leave
just you know they just kind of go with
the flow sort of thing
but the point that i'm making is if you
want to be successful as an entrepreneur
if you wanna have an entrepreneur's
mindset you need to think start leaning
into the other two areas of thinking
okay
outside of the box now we're talking
you're
i don't have any boxes here on my desk
anywhere unfortunately but y'all know
what a box looks like there's stuff
inside it and there's stuff outside it
and there's a barrier around it
most people spend all the time in the
box
when you visit the surroundings of the
bach outside of the box then you see
opportunities that the people inside
aren't touching now you're now you've
graduated to like the top 1 right now
you're paying attention to new things
you see new opportunities you see ways
to develop something build on something
you can mash up
a few different ideas one of the uh
great thinkers in this area is a guy by
the name of james altucher he's written
quite a few books he's active on twitter
he has a blog
i've mentioned choose yourself which is
one of his books several times
and that spends a lot of time on outside
of the box thinking
um one of the things he's talked about
is mashing up ideas right like
entrepreneurs in cars together boom you
have a little bit of idea sex and you
have something new that comes out of
that
channel's evolved since then obviously
since the very beginning but you get the
idea
the third type of thinking not even
seeing the box thinking this is what um
steve jobs was made popular for
you should consider paying attention to
things like biographies like just watch
them if you're not a reader just watch
them or get an audio book and listen to
them but steve jobs was known for being
a not even seeing the box kind of
thinker if it wasn't for
uh jobs we all wouldn't be using devices
like this i don't have a blackberry
kicking around anywhere but i have a
blackberry from back in the day with the
button keypad and it was jobs that said
you know what we don't need that keypad
let's get rid of it
let's make it a full screen and we'll
give the users a brand new experience he
basically
if if he didn't come up with that
again we would all be using keypad still
probably very very conventional pushing
buttons on a keypad all right outside of
the box thinking is what
uh
breaks into parabolic bounds like when
we're talking about putting a little
dent in the universe outside of the box
thinking you can do that you want to put
a massive dent in the universe not even
seeing the box right steve jobs and
apple i mean one of the most uh valuable
companies out there today even even
after he's long gone so you know it
speaks volumes for the type of thinking
that he had and the culture that he uh
infused into the office space especially
with the c-suite leaders that basically
took over after he died right
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you